enfin le nommer souris est située à à
peine 45 minutes du centre-ville de
saint-louis ici on entre dans le comté
rural de saint charles dans un terreau
républicain nik software a été élu
représentant du district à la chambre du
missouri en 2016 aujourd'hui ils tentent
d'accéder au sénat est pour l'instant sa
campagne se passe plutôt bien il
multiplie rassemblement militant
les républicains qui je parle sont fous
de joie lorsqu'ils apprennent que c'est
moi qui a parrainé la loi anti
avortement ils me demandent des
autographes et me demande ce qu'ils
peuvent faire pour m'aider
il y a ceux qui l'admirent et ceux qui
le détestent à l'extérieur de la salle
où se tient le rassemblement républicain
une centaine de militants pro choix ont
fait la route depuis saint louis pour
perturber la rencontre
la stratégie a fonctionné le jeune
avocat avoue que bien de ses supporters
ont décidé de rebrousser chemin
mais les manifestations contre sa loi ne
l'arrêtent pas
je sais qu'il y à des manifestations ce
soir je leur dis bienvenue et je suis
ouvert au débat en notant que ce soit
pacifique mais le débat sur l'avortement
semble déjà clos est sans appel il parle
plutôt d'éduquer ses adversaires il
croit profondément que cette loi est la
volonté de ses électeurs et de dieu
il veut donc aller plus loin après
l'avortement chirurgical il veut
s'attaquer à la pilule abortive dès
l'automne
l'objectif est d'interdire ces pilules
au missouri et même d'empêcher leur
envoi par la poste
parce que des choses qu'on pensait on
était à l'abri en fait on n'est pas
l'abri yara route n'est pas étonné des
nouvelles prises de position de next web
là c'est juste le premier domino est en
fait on s'attend tous à skis et beaucoup
de choses qui arrivent et qui continue
dans la même
dans la même direction c'est en fait
qu'ils vont peut-être grappillé a des
choses à gauche et à droite en tant que
femme elle dit ne plus reconnaître le
missouri où il avait décidé de s'établir
il ya quinze ans c'est pas seulement la
question de l'avortement des choses
comme ça c'est un exemple dans un
mouvement général où on se sent
pas aussi bien que les autres pas traité
comme les autres on a peur et c'est la
porte c'est bon maintenant c'est ça et
demain ça va être quoi elle et son
conjoint sange maintenant sérieusement à
quitter le missouri il va falloir qu'on
pense à notre futur aussi nous en tant
que citoyens c'est moi je peux pas
rester ici dans un endroit on considère
moins que quelqu'un d'autre donc et nous
on a la chance parce que enfin nous
avons tous les deux la halle aux menaces
hérité donc la france nous accueillera
je pense les bras ouverts
nick square lui voit plus que j'aime et
son avenir dans un état de plus en plus
à son image et il n'est pas près
d'arrêter sa croisade il prie pour que
sa loi soit adoptée par tous les états
américains
nous avons besoin que tous les états
reconnaissent le caractère sacré de la
vie et qu'il bénisse l'avortement dit il
gonflé à bloc par l'abandon de l'arrêt
roe contre wade est porté par ses
convictions il se dit prêt pour de
nouvelles batailles
peu importe les divisions qu'elle
provoque et même si de toute évidence
elle rend la vie de moins en moins
paisible au missouri et si valérie
gamache radio canada aux farines